[Music]
Junior Team of the Year sponsored by the
Langstone Cliff Hotel Dawlish United
ladies Football Club under 18 on the
back of a hugely successful 2016-17
season
Dawlish United took the leap into
under-18 football the season the girls
had was incredible as they went on to
win another treble of league League Cup
and Devon FA Cups winning 20 out of 22
games to put this achievement into
context they are the only team in Devon
out of over 1,700 teams in youth and
adult football to have won the treble in
each of the past two seasons on top of
the team success there were also four
players selected to play for their
County and another four players selected
for the Exeter City girls Development
Center the success of this team is down
to their incredible hard work and
dedication and was the best possible way
to finish as the girls move on from
youth football Newton Abbot water polo
Under 17's Newton Abbot under-17 water
polo team have had a very successful
year building on previous success in the
2017 season they won the Bristol and
West water polo league junior tournament
and the Devon County under-17 League and
knockout cup they achieved this by
winning every game they played in the
Devon league they scored a hundred and
sixty three goals and conceded
forty-seven and in the Bristol and West
League they scored two hundred and
thirty three conceding 86 the team is
made up of a group of highly dedicated
talented individuals who played
fantastically as a team building on
several years of training and experience
they trained upwards of five hours a
week several doing more members of the
team have played for the county the
region and several of them have been
selected to train with the National
Academy preparing for selection for the
national squads
Southwest underwater hockey under 12s
team Southwest under 12 underwater
hockey team have played and won the
national regions championships as well
as defended their title as national club
under 12 champions the team trained up
to four hours a week and at such a young
age are incredibly dedicated and focused
on their sports they are supportive of
each other
and work effectively as a team they have
a great work ethic and incredible
sportsmanship both of which are key
elements throughout the club the junior
Club has seen incredible growth over the
last 12 months with a club continuing to
go from strength to strength we're all
very excited to see what they can do
next year
[Music]